thanks everyone for coming my name is
Peter Barton I'm the Associate Director
of the Symons Institute for the theory
of computing let me say a few words
about the Simons Institute it's the the
leading venue for collaborative research
in theoretical computer science
it was established in in 2012 with a
generous grant from the Simons
Foundation and it brings together the
world's leading researchers in
theoretical computer science and related
fields as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars to explore
deep unsolved problems about the nature
and limits of computation and as well as
promoting fundamental research on the
foundations of computer science it aims
to expand the horizons of the field by
exploring other disciplines through our
computational lens motivated by the fact
that phenomena in many fields including
physics biology economics or the models
that those fields have developed for
those phenomena are intrinsically
computational in nature and the insights
gained from these these explorations
often reflect back to the theory of
computation opening new directions and
tonight's theoretically speaking event
certainly has this flavor it's brought
together a very distinguished group to
discuss the intersection between
algorithms and the law from from
multiple perspectives law ethics
philosophy and computer science we're
very interested in exploring what are
the challenges and opportunities prevent
presented by artificial intelligence and
by algorithms more generally it's become
a more pressing issue as AI systems are
being applied to a broader range of
tasks and having a real impact on
societies and individuals and and some
of these are very familiar and some are
new so things like deciding whose
creditworthy deciding what news and
messages will be passed on to us
deciding actions that a self-driving car
will take deciding on guilt and parole
deciding on who gets a job interview
what are the social and humanitarian
risks and how is society addressed them
particularly through legal mechanisms
and in the other direction what
opportunities might this technology
provide in the arena of law and
governance we're delighted to have a
very distinguished group of panelists to
discuss these topics Martha Minow from
Harvard University Patricia Williams
from Columbia University
Shafi goldwasser from the Symons
Institute and Elliot Schrage from
Facebook
we start with a brief introduction to
each and then I'd like to say a little
bit about the format that we'll use
tonight so Martha Minow is the 300th
anniversary University professor at
Harvard University and 300 years old she
was a few years ago when she stepped
down as dean of the Harvard Law School
she's been teaching at Harvard Law
School since 1981 and is an expert in
human rights and advocacy for members of
racial and religious minorities and for
women children and people with
disabilities she's vice chair of the
board of the Legal Services Corporation
a bipartisan government-sponsored
organization that provides civil legal
assistance to low-income Americans and
she writes and teaches about
privatization military justice and
ethnic and religious conflict and she's
been elected to the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences so big well welcome to
Martha Patricia Williams is the James
elder professor of law at Columbia Law
School she's just just between us and
she's also served on the faculties of
the University of Wisconsin School of
Law City University of New York Law
School and Golden Gate University School
of Law
she's been deputy city attorney for the
office of the Los Angeles City Attorney
and has served a staff lawyer for the
Western center on law and poverty and
has published widely in the areas of
race gender and law and on other issues
of legal theory and legal writing her
books include the alchemy of race and
Rights which won the Bruce K gold a
Gould Book Award the roosters egg and
seeing a colorblind future the paradox
of race Pat has also been a columnist
for the nation she writes the column the
diary of a mad law professor on issues
of social justice she's been a MacArthur
Fellow has received the Alumni
achievement award from Wellesley and the
Graduate Society medal from Harvard and
served on the board of trustees at
Wellesley College the board of the Andy
Warhol foundation and has been
to the American Philosophical Society
welcome
[Applause]
Shafi goldwasser is the director of the
sons Institute for the theory of
computing here at UC Berkeley and
professor electric engineering computer
science at UC Berkeley RS a professor of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science at MIT and professor of computer
science and applied mathematics if the
Weitzman Institute of Science in Israel
so she doesn't easily give up positions
[Laughter]
she's she's won the ACM Turing Award has
twice been awarded the girdle prize and
has been elected the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences the National Academy
of Science in the National Academy of
Engineering welcome to I'm gonna invite
each panelist to give us their
perspective on a particular theme in
this area of algorithms in the law and
after we've heard from each one we're
aiming to have a discussion among the
panelists and and I guess my role is to
help spark spark that discussion I have
to say I was a little apprehensive about
that my expertise is firmly on the
technology side of this this debate but
but then we've had we really have a
diverse range of perspectives here and
you know after chatting with with with
each of them
I realize it's going to be very lively
and lots of fun I've enjoyed all those
conversations so I'm confident it'll be
a fascinating discussion and it's
unlikely that anything I say will mess
with that I'm really looking forward to
it I should say I might need to call a
halt to that discussion at some point
because we do want a chance for the
audience to ask questions also
so we'll reserve some time for that but
one caveat
everyone here is speaking as individuals
not on behalf of their employers so you
know they can't answer questions on
their employers behalf all right so
Martha we start with you
so Shafi invited you to give a talk in
this forum and you suggested this panel
he'll format and you know you have lots
to tell us about where rights and take
ecology collide let's say and about the
opportunities there as well and so but
perhaps I guess maybe it'd be good to
start with why we're doing this and how
it came about well thank you Peter
and thank you Shafi for this invitation
and thanked you pat and thank you Elliot
because I just think it's more fun if we
walk into a bar together so and we'll
learn something really water so water I
am as Peter said the vice-chair of the
entity that funds legal services for
poor people so in that context that is
absolutely obvious to me that we will
never provide lawyers for all the poor
people in this country who need them and
who deserve them and what that means in
practice for example is that people who
are tenants and have a problem with the
law end up representing themselves 99
percent of them represent themselves and
people who are landlords have lawyers
and the typical hearing and a housing
court is about three or four minutes and
if you have a lawyer your chances of
doing better of succeeding are much much
much better so that's that's context led
the Legal Services Corporation to give
out technology innovation grants to
grantee organizations 133 around the
country who have developed some
fascinating efforts using artificial
intelligence using other kinds of
computer algorithms to help for example
a veteran navigates the Veterans
Administration medical care to help
people actually get some legal advice
so I'm interested I see great promise at
the same time my state like many others
has started to use algorithms in the
criminal justice system to decide who
should and should not get cash bail who
should and should not get parole and
this I am really really worried about
and so when I had the great good fortune
to spend a year at Radcliffe where I
also was able to be
with my old friends hat and meet a new
friend Shafi and we were describing what
do we want to do this year I think you
said I want to think about algorithms
she learning machine learning and a
group of us said oh we all want to do
that so out of that came a I think a
really fascinating conversation
Cynthia Dworkin here is another key
member of that group and out of the hat
came a class so we actually taught a
class together and this was a feat of
Technology because it cut across four
institutions across the country students
from computer science and from law
that's the bigger divide frankly than
between Boston New York and Berkeley and
we found that we have a lot to talk
about a lot of questions a lot of
possibilities so I would add to your
list Peter of the kinds of issues to
think about blockchain runs afoul of the
right to be forgotten which is now a
paradigm that the European Union has
described has has actually implemented
there are collisions of that nature
emerging every day and at the same time
there are technological innovations that
bypass legal regulations they do an end
run around the prohibition for example
of using race or gender in employment I
don't have to describe how Ober doesn't
end run about around many laws but other
kinds of technological issues you know
face face recognition and should it be
used by law enforcement and what do we
do with the fact that at least at the
moment it's not very good at recognizing
the faces of African Americans and some
others privacy issues I think the risk
score question is not just an issue in
the criminal justice system but also in
the banking system because if the
datasets that are relied upon are
themselves reflective of larger problems
in the society structural racism for
example to see
about who has credit worthiness based on
past creditworthiness who is likely to
be re-arrested based on where the police
have been located not only is the
algorithm going to be fed you know
garbage in garbage out but now it's also
another step removed from accountability
in democracy and it's less accessible to
a democratic process partly because it
looks like it's more technological and
more scientific this European Union
point is an increasing issue that is
there it's regulation coming in from
different parts of the world and so even
if the predicate in the United States
largely is we're not going to regulate
its free speech or its private
enterprise it doesn't matter it is going
to be regulate it is being regulated and
it's not just the European Union
Australia the UK Singapore we're all
involved in this and I'm looking at
Elliott because he's been trying to
navigate that so if the United States is
not at the table somebody else is making
the decisions and that seems like a
missed opportunity and we should be at
the table as my own view I also think
that there are opportunities beyond the
the kind that I described about access
to justice that we should be pursuing so
in our class we have the chance to think
about how some tools from cryptography
zero knowledge proof other kinds of
tools might be available to help better
implement rights like protecting the
sources that journalists have and so we
there's just so many rich conversations
we should be having both ways what are
the tools what are the possibilities
that the new AI and computer science
revolution affords and what are the
concerns that lawyers and ethicists and
people concerned about governance may
have now I just say one more thing the
course was enormous fun and we will have
different iterations of it but here was
frankly
biggest learning we don't speak the same
language we have a long way to go to
even have these conversations and I'll
just flag a few just words that we use
to mean different things fairness
fairness I would learned for many
computer scientists means accuracy which
is you know that seems relevant but for
lawyers that's well maybe relevant but
it's one of many many different
dimensions which might include
participation transparency opportunities
for review and having conversations
about do you want this and having the
response being why would you want this
totally fascinating another different
word or word with different meanings is
proof
what does proof well I am now feeling
embarrassed that lawyers are pretty
vague about what we mean about proof and
we resist the idea of actually putting a
number on the probability oh and that's
actually if I it's a produce a mistrial
if if a lawyer actually says here's the
actual way to consider what the
instructions from the juror from the
judge mean and in computer science
you know quite beautiful and elegant
conceptions of proof and probabilities
so that was that was another one and I I
think just one more is transparency so
with machine learning in particular you
know now that I have some beginning
understanding about the multiple levels
at which machine learning is translating
data into more refined and abstracted
and abstracted levels my question about
but what's going on in the inside seems
naive but I'll tell you that is my
question what's going on on the inside
and transparency you tell me but I think
computer scientists have a different
idea about what that involves so I think
we have a lot of work to do there's a
lot of promise and a lot of peril if we
don't do that work
thanks brother
so pet your your column the the diary of
a mad law professor had many very
thought-provoking articles with titles
like Americans are finding new ways to
join the surveillance state and why
everyone should care about mass
incarceration also you've you were a
co-organizer of this workshop with
Cynthia to work with the SANS Institute
this week entitled wrong at the root
racial bias and the tension between
numbers and words in non Internet data
and in discussions that we've had you
raise questions about how the concept of
self is affected by the widening use of
algorithms by numerical representation
of individuals that that use implies and
you know issues like the difficulties of
challenging the status that's imposed on
us by an algorithm you know that's a
that's a very broad range of topics
would you like to I think my concern
begins with that of a contract before
Sarah teach of contracts and I don't
like seeing things handled as though
they were contract when they actually
are issues of criminal law because
they're completely different standards
and so this begins with a concern about
proprietary notions being the central
value of economic exchange embodied in
contract law and if efficiency and
economic value is the most important
thing then and you put an algorithm into
somebody's ankle bracelet or you put an
algorithm into a predictive mechanism
for whether or not somebody is going to
be released or not from jail
you are bypassing a system that says we
look at each individual each case and
controversy that's what our
constitutional protection is it's an
individually based assessment of who
this human being is in time if they've
done something in the past that's wrong
our criminal narcissism figures out some
remediation that brings healing into the
present algorithms predict what you're
going to do in the future what you
haven't done in other words but if it's
also done by an algorithm that
is owned by a private corporation whose
ultimate obligation is not to the public
not to grace Purefoy but to the
stakeholders of a corporation which are
the stockholders then that's mixing
functions it's a conflict of interest
built into the machine as far as I'm
concerned it also makes it very hard to
excavate exactly what's being judged
what's being put into the black box that
decides at least part of your fate and
at least some of the algorithms have
been suspected of or actually proved to
take into account things like where you
live your zip code and that's not about
your behavior
that's judging you by a group of
fication that if it were in if a police
officer we're doing that we'd call it
profiling stereotyping it's
impermissible in the law but it's buried
it's invisible in a proprietary we don't
have the right to bring that out in
court and we in its it's so it's a kind
of silent witness which also violates
the idea that you have n trials the
right or if you're going to have these
very consequential things of freedom or
not you're going to be able to
cross-examine the witnesses against you
and these sort of mechanical witnesses
or that's an aspect that I think is
simply not it's not fully taken account
of in these very consequential uses a
second concern I have is that it is very
disembody it is and by disembodied I
mean dehumanizing it abstract suss and
certainly one aspect is that it judges
us by a cohort by which you know if it's
race if it's gender if it's again where
you live it judges you by pinpoints that
don't necessarily have anything to do
with you and I'll give you a personal
example at Columbia we use a system
called canvas and when I was being
trained to use this it's a it's a it's a
platform for the non academics where you
get to talk to the students get to talk
to one another during the course of a of
a class you know you could put things on
it and everybody discusses it but it it
frequently it runs while you're giving a
lecture and I accidentally discovered
that actually somewhere in the IT office
they're ranking the end
our faculty by how many hits our
conversations are had among students
during the course of a class of a class
time yeah yeah so it's literally ranking
you according to the Kim Kardashian
scale as far as I'm concerned and I'm
somebody who always tells my students
close your computers you know what turn
off your cell phones we are going to
talk to one another we're gonna have a
different kind of conversation well it
turns out that as a metric of my status
as professor if in fact I'm being ranked
by this abstraction not of what comes
out of my mouth but how many times my
students are talking during course of it
it doesn't matter whether or not I'm
wearing a bright pink
you know diamond-encrusted bustier you
know it didn't it doesn't matter what
they are talking about that those data
points are abstracted from what is the
substance of what's actually being
taught and you know it's sort of it
incentivizes me to be splashy or to
generate conversation in very different
ways and that that that shift from the
substance or from the particularity of
what is actually going on in a situation
to the you know to sort of like in
facial recognition you see all these
data points substituting for a face and
it's a new kind of persona I mean if one
thinks of the persona as in in Greek
theater literally a mask behind which
the or through which it's it's something
through which one speaks again in
American jurisprudence that persona
through which one speaks is a protection
of both the internal privacy but it's
also the right to invent oneself the
white create oneself the right to to be
judged by what it is that you do that
you present to the world and this is a
kind of abstraction it seems to me that
emulates some of the worst features
about how we tag people who are
stateless how we tag people who are
disenfranchised or marginalized how we
tag people who are african-american in
the society as the number one example of
people who as WB Dubois put it suffer
from double double double consciousness
because you're never
simply to think about what you're
thinking about you always have to be
aware of who is looking at you and what
you know what they're thinking are they
talking are they saying the right things
and that's the kind of disembody and
quality that I think this brings to the
table that is that we have to think
about how we want to what what if that's
a perspective we want to become
normative because it internalizes the
panopticon in ways that I con secuence
is I think could be quite serious and
you see this as an extraordinary stress
in populations who are already enduring
that kind of constant surveillance if
this is the new norm for everybody I
expect you will see those kinds of
stresses magnified finally of course
this is an assorted of mechanism with a
very long memory and it's a mistaken
sort of mechanism because we really
haven't had the kind of conversations I
think I hope we are beginning to have
about coos in what population and who's
in and who's in the comparative
populations how those populations have
been set up who is called black who is
called white who is called male or
female in our the simple examples of
what you can get wrong I have friends
who are married
he is normatively white I suppose and
she is chinese-american and they had
twins in the hospital the nurse came in
and saw the mother with one of the
babies and put on the certificate in the
hospital that the baby was an Asian a
few minutes later the second baby came
in with the father and a different nurse
came in and wrote white and so it's kind
of funny but it also means that if that
indoors at a cat occurs as a
categorization it indicates very
different life chances and that's
magnified if you saw one baby is white
and one baby is black I mean it but but
you can and it's not just about the
perception of people's prejudices you
walk through the world it's built into
black box medicine about who is measured
is what whether or not you're going to
amp up certain outcomes because you
believe that that that that race is
embodied in ways that that that the
justified what would have been some of
what we've been talking this week for
example asthma monitors are actually
adjusted for african-american lung
capacity because that is a metric that
goes all the way the spirometer it's
still adjusted isn't it it's horrible oh
it's hot I'm sorry I think we disagree
yeah yeah no it but it's adjusted
because there was a built into this
machine and the barometer is 200 years
old and so it was built into the
assumption that slaves had different
lung capacity it has never been taken
out of the machine so they're still
adjustments my son has asthma and it's
adjusted for african-american lung
capacity which is different from every
other human being on the planet and that
is just wrong but these are things which
are now being built more efficiently and
invisibly into these into not just the
old-fashioned hand pump of you know
breathing into it but into assumptions
that have to do with living or liver
function kidney function blood
osteoporosis rates and so forth and then
this is these are unquestioned they're
unquestioned and they have the authority
that displaces again the human
interaction of what we thought of was
going to be precision medicine which is
each body speaking but instead is being
normed according to ancient and
incoherent biologists categories
biologists we're bringing the history of
this kind of segregation and now we are
rebuy ala gisin and in very palpable
boys the final thing I want to say is
that because these machines store data
essentially forever the right to be
forgotten isn't simply about clearing
your credit record it pins you in a way
that I think of as a kind of
institutionalized traumatic reiteration
when
in Psych Hutton's psychoanalytic theory
if you can never forget something
it's literally like it's repeated over
and over and over again it becomes
confining this inability to reinvent
this inability to become a new person to
emerge from your last worst moment and
so we're we're in scribing people with a
new kind of status we're creating new
caste systems which make it impossible
for people to escape and in
anglo-american jurisprudence and most of
Western dignitary and jurisprudence the
concept of amnesty which mark is written
about so eloquently is about the ability
to forget that you are forgiving and for
it isn't just forgiveness it is also
forgetting you put it behind you with
this kind of mechanical long-term memory
it becomes impossible to forget and you
become literally cast as a member of a
caste forever so chef he's going to tell
us a little bit about some potential
applications of computer science I guess
broadly in the legal sphere one of the
things that chef is famous for is her
work on zero knowledge proof so being
able to verify that you know a secret
without revealing the secret so think of
a protocol allows me to prove to you
that I know a password to something
without actually sharing a password with
you or anyone else and people have
proposed applications of this technology
and verifying honesty without
sacrificing privacy for instance in
verifying compliance with a nuclear
disarmament treaty without revealing
perhaps national secrets or maybe more
mundane lis in verifying financial
transactions without revealing details
of those transactions or perhaps with
respecting the right to to have things
forgotten you know in a sequence of you
know transactions of that sort so Shafi
was like tell us a little more about
computer scientists in the bar and how
you don't speak as eloquently as the
other members I will use slides okay and
we have slide NP okay so I guess I am a
theoretical computer
and in fact the Simon's Institute is you
guys can turn around if you want the
Simon's Institute is an institute that
is about fun it's about computer science
and how what it can do for computing and
other sciences in society it's a
relatively young field and so certainly
a young field compared to it too long
and I guess it's kind of broadly defined
if what you just used I wanted to use
sort of intuitive definition is we
studied the fundamentals of what can and
cannot be done with computers and
computer programs and but more to the
point of this particular seminar panel I
think that over the last sort of 4050
years theorists in computer science have
shown sort of the ability to take very
vague accounts and formalize them things
like what is it we want from prime what
do we mean when we say well we want
private communication or what do we mean
when we say that we want to be able to
compute on data while maintaining the
privacy of data or what does it mean to
define signal 1084 things to events to
happen at the same time so these seem to
be very intuitive things but they
require definition but why did the wave
acharya definition is because once we
use computers to that's supposedly
guarantee privacy or they guarantee
immunity or they enable you to compute
on data without actually looking at the
data we need to say we need to be able
to set a goal for this system and we
want to give a precise mathematical goal
so that later we can possibly prove
mathematically that this system
satisfies these definitions so it's not
good enough to have a vague definition
we need to have a formal way to talk
about these things and what does this
have to do with panel and with law so as
I understand it and actually you both
confirmed it I mean we've confirmed it
in private but you've also said it in
this panel that law is sort of
intentionally vague so the judges can
use their judgment and discretion in
deciding in court cases sort of on a
case-by-case basis and use context and
review in order to render you know
justice
and that's that's wonderful however so
we all know that you know that we've got
a lot of data out there and regardless
whether we have data or not we have
automated systems that stand to make a
lot of progress and one of the things
that Martha talked about was making the
judicial system more efficient by having
helped two people who who between
renters and and low in landlords but you
know health by disease control by trend
prediction predictions financial markets
economic growth driving so that we can
get to where we want to go in time you
know
facial-recognition which has downsides
but it also has upsides in vision if you
look at your MRI oh and you want to
detect diseases and you want to detect
it reliably and not just because of the
mood that the doctor has that day
apparently I know that for breast cancer
they claims that the same doctor if he
sees it you know two weeks later he
might give completely different judgment
and we would like to have some
consistency in reliability and as you
pointed out it's now being used also for
things like policing bail credit rating
things which should have major societal
impacts okay maybe major societal
consequences and it's very important
that in order to take advantage of the
efficiency that the system's afford
perhaps not for certain areas but
certainly for others that we are able to
write laws okay that govern the behavior
of these systems and in order to be able
to write laws it's not going to be
enough to use this vague language so
since we're talking about sort of these
systems that actually have kind of a
well-defined input-output behavior then
we need to make our laws more precise we
need to give definitions what it is that
you want such systems to adhere to and I
think that the order computer science
essentially it's ahead of experience to
in having done exactly that so how to
take these kind of again vague notions
and maybe give it a precise definition
now who is to say what's the right
definition I think this is a an issue
that can come up in and that's why we
need to talk to
so in a sense I think that people like
lawyers exactly lawyers policymakers
they need to tell us to discuss with us
what it is that the law it mandates what
it is that a system should provide but
then we would need our expertise in
order to actually give formal
definitions that satisfy this so the
reason that I'm optimistic that we can
do that is that there you know I'm a
cryptographer actually within several
computer science and cryptography is a
field where we we've done that several
times over so we have given some precise
definition to kind of intuitive notions
and not only in that efficient we're not
just out for definitions we are out for
building systems which are better so we
want to enable progress you know we'll
be able to do things we couldn't do
before like privacy and simultaneity and
contract signing and and commerce and so
forth but we want to do that the right
way so once we have sort of defined sort
of the notions then we can come up with
systems and prove that the notions are
satisfied so some of these examples that
I just want to mention in word I mean I
don't want to teach you I mean I do I
know this is not the the platform and
also from the audience I think a lot of
you know this but I just want to give a
few words about some examples which are
good both from the point of view that
they actually do this thing that I
promise that they define an intuitive
notion but they're also applicable for
the law and they've been shown actually
useful to enable things like for example
Martha talked about accountability that
there's some feeling that by having
these automated system we're gonna have
less accountability but I actually think
that we can use some tools that we've
developed to get more accountability
rather than less so some on this idea
that it's less accountability I think
it's a little bit because viewing this
what we do is a bit like voodoo and and
in some areas it still is voodoo
so these facial recognition systems they
work but we don't know exactly how to
explain why or they recognize cats and
dogs that's really Peters thing right
not the cats and dogs but but okay right
he's a theorist actually but I mean
there's a lot of talk about how AI
manages to do things without explain
but I think this is we are in a certain
point in time this is not the end of the
story okay so lets me just say something
about these examples just to illustrate
how there are some things we can do
which are remarkable and it can be
useful for the law in my opinion so
there's this thing called secure
multi-party computation and what is that
so first of all maybe what it enables
because we are kind of a general
audience I would say it will enable
doing things like advanced medical
research and medical treatment while
being compliant with HIPAA regulations
so what is a secure multi-party
computation again before defining it
which is kind of the opposite of what we
do at interval computer science but it's
better for presentation it's a way for a
bunch of computers each of which has
different data to collaborate and let's
say run programs on their union of
everybody's data without actually
sharing the data so somehow we can use
the wisdom of all these different
computers to derive conclusions and
medicine or research without actually
giving each other's data and in fact
this is a I think intuitively should you
should understood kind of believe that
this is extremely useful and in fact
it's gotten to the point that even
there's a congressional definition so
I'm just giving you the Congressional
definition rather than the computer
science definition and they say the term
most secure multi-party computation
means a computerized system that enables
different participating entities in
possession of private sets of data to
link and aggregate their data sets for
the exclusive purpose of performing a
number of people computation without
transferring or otherwise revealing
private data to each other and this in
fact is useful for things like you know
if you have different hospitals I don't
know here there's dana-farber in MGH
because I was at MIT before and I know
the names of the hospitals they're here
what you have Stanford UCSF at the Bates
yeah and so let's say they want to
collaborate they have different patient
sets they might be genomic Institute's
and clearly if they could pull their
data together then they could reach
better conclusions they could do better
research because nobody has enough data
you know this draws much conclusion as
you want but people would say that
you're not allowed to give medical
records out to another hospital or to a
drug company so can you actually derive
these conclusions without providing
without
giving out the data and this theorems
which were approved in by computer
scientists show how to do it and and it
but before they show how to do it they
define what it means to do it and what
it means is that you will be able to
conduct the research and get the outcome
of the research without knowing anything
else about other people's data then
what's implied by the outcome of the
research so the definition is actually
very abstract and seems to be very ideal
and you can yet you can satisfy it
what's another example that you could do
with this which has some kind of a
legalistic flavor to it
so for example in Boston they were
running some people wanted to know what
is the wage disparity between men and
women among Boston companies and they
don't want to reveal of course what
they're paying to whom but they couldn't
be university convinced many companies
in ha in Boston to go through a
multiparty secure computation where they
would determine what is the average
salary of a man was the average salary
of a woman in Boston and then these
companies could just decide for
themselves are they above or below so
there was some sort of benchmark but
this was that no shaming involved just a
way to determine what the average is and
this is obviously something that I don't
see how we can do that without these
methods without the mathematics and this
is progress you know this is progress
that I think would have also impact on
what is legal and what's illegal you
know in terms of wages okay what's the
other thing is there an arch proofs so
my son's couldn't convince me to put
this picture on this is what I used to
look like I think I still look like that
but they claim I don't but in any case
so this is zero knowledge processes from
the 80s actually Berkeley and the idea
is that these are mechanisms to
demonstrate that facts are true without
giving information why they're true and
that is very relevant you know for
something like what Peter said you know
they prove that you are the right person
who has authority to access let's say
records on a computer or to purchase
something on Amazon but it's also useful
for things that could are connected to
to the law and in particular there's
sort of recent paper that my students I
wrote and that is about how to help to
ensure accountability quite the opposite
of lack of accountability in the courts
so the story here is that people
probably have heard about the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act which
allows essentially you know in a saying
- or I think it's the NSA to wiretap
foreign nationals
and then there's some sort of a body of
secret laws that determines when it's
allowed and when it's not allowed but
since the laws are secret and the court
and the surveillance acts are secret you
know it's all done without any kind of
accountability so wouldn't it be nice if
you were able to sort of prove that you
are inconsistent with some sort of body
of secret laws without actually
revealing what those laws were or what
the surveillance requests were and
there's not a they're not proof seem to
be totally suited to it now this is all
theory I'm not saying that I know how to
write the set of secret laws as a
computer program and then to prove that
that computer program was executed
properly but you know theory does have a
tendency to translate to practice when
it offers something good so I'm
optimistic these things can be done and
this foreign surveillance you know maybe
it's the least of our problems because
as Americans there's actually a federal
docket that allows you know the FBI to
request Facebook or Google or any of
these other companies the access to your
digital content and your emails and so
forth and of course you have to go to a
federal judge and request a court order
and but it turns out that even though
these these surveillance orders are
supposed to be sort of revealed to the
public after a certain enough amount of
time passes and it's not anyway and it's
no longer insecure because obviously
while you're being surveillance if the
person who was being suppose knew about
it it's not a good idea even I with my
limited criminal abilities know that so
but they're in it's written into the law
that this has to be this secrecy has to
be lifted within 30 to 60 days and it
turns out that it does she doesn't it
doesn't happen in fact so this judge
Smith from Texas wrote a few papers
about it saying that these judgments are
made in the shade
and that it's gagged seal basically
things are not revealed and that means
that there is no opportunity to
scrutinize these laws there's no
opportunity to to check whether it was
given you know rightfully the the
surveillance order or not why these
surveillance orders were issued and so
forth or even what the magnitude of the
problem is it's in fact the only way
that we know how many of these things
happen is because I think companies such
as Facebook and so forth they released
the in Google and in Microsoft they
released these reports every year saying
how many surveillance orders they were
asked for but we have no way to check
that that's correct they might be under
playing it they might be over playing it
they don't say why they were requested
so it's hard to say for which purpose
you know the FBI asked for it and the
reason I'm talking about this is because
again we could build a system that uses
both zero knowledge proof and
multi-party comes the cure multi-party
computation that if the judges are we
were willing to adopt it and we work in
which Art Smith to try to convince other
judges to adopt it could enforce federal
judges to somehow secretly commit to the
surveillance orders that they've granted
and then make sure that they actually
lift the secrecy orders and also be able
to aggregate how many of these
surveillance requests were issued and
there's a whole architecture to it and
that's already technology so in any case
I think that's all I want to say I guess
my conclusions are that I think the laws
should be coming and they are coming to
make automated system just I think that
it's important that you know lawyers
don't just rule it out because they
think it's too dangerous or too vague so
because then we will miss a great missed
opportunity so I think we we need to
talk to each other to be able to
understand what it is that should be
enforced for these systems when should
they be used when shouldn't they be used
possibly and certainly we're not going
to use the judgments of these systems or
we shouldn't be using these judgments or
these systems as fit a complete but it
could be an assistive tool to pee
for you know and helping them make
decisions and then I had a little video
because it's Friday night and you're
very very good about coming here my
video is from Monty Python and the
reason that it's relevant to this talk
is because then my title was my title
was a what can computer science do for
us okay and it reminded me of this
particular skit not just from us from
our fathers and from our fathers fathers
from our fathers fathers fathers yeah
and from our fathers father's father's
father don't leave at a point and what
are they ever given us in return
the aqueduct what yeah product Oh
sanitation oh yeah the Sanitation reg
remember what the city used to be like
yeah all I'll grant you the aqueduct of
Sanitation of two things our own agenda
and the roads well yeah obviously not
roads I mean the roads go without saying
no they apart from the Sanitation the
aqueduct on the road irrigation medicine
education yeah all right fair enough and
the wine yeah yeah that's something we'd
really miss maybe the Romans left public
bonds and it's safe to walk in the
streets at night now reg yeah they
certainly know how to keep order let's
face it the only ones who could in a
place like this or Ivan apart from the
Sanitation the medicine education wine
Public Order irrigation grows a fresh
water system and public health what are
the Romans ever done for us
Oh
so fascinating any reactions I wanted to
speak to techno optimism because it
seems to me that's a force that is both
wonderful and I don't want to present
myself as a techno pessimist in all of
this but I I agree that there's nothing
new Under the Sun and and I also agree
that you know I can't imagine not having
my computer I love what it has brought
to me in terms of roads and sanitation
another name for technomage optimism is
a kind of new age manifest destiny and
that's quite dangerous and it's being
carried forth with a sense of
self-congratulation
and lack of regulation and monopoly
power where the guiding construct is you
know art you know and again I don't mean
I this is not a I think it's inevitable
this is how we have to express it you
know how can we our designers put into
this system something that gains trust
as though the population to trust is
something that has to be homegrown
within the context of its engagement
with this system but you're doing it so
that you're you know I think there were
you know we've had conversations which
basically it is the technology
developers who are giving voice to these
populations where you are never going to
have trust from those who have been
cultured by a democracy or
representative governmental system where
oh damn it I have my own voice you know
and I will speak or not speak and so I
think there's also a way in which this
production of comfort or consent or
engagement it within this privatized
model of help us make it work better is
a is-is-is
is sort of begging to be part of a
utopian project but particularly from
from you know from those voices like the
people whose we're not served by the bus
you know who have been through certain
dystopic versions of this and that's and
that's something that I think there's no
substitute for but a kind of you know a
close examination of unintended
consequences a close examination of
where there is a kind of blind hubris in
the sense that this is going to bring
health wealth and happiness as if you've
ever seen a little film called DNA
dreams that the Beijing genetics
Institute talks about in terms of our
you know the more we know about all of
this it's going to bring health wealth
and happiness and higher IQs and it's
part of their advertising and and and I
am again please do not interpret this as
a Luddite instrument I'm just very
cautious about the incredibly layered
ways in which this intersects with
society displaces governance dis
embodies sentient beings at every level
and and and and too much confidence that
this is nothing but a good thing also
has to be built into that model that is
you know I I don't know how else to you
know I sometimes wonder if you know if
law if law itself as we know it is going
to be displaced by these new standards
and by this and and if there's
consciousness within these companies
these corporations the search for
efficient outcomes is there a mechanism
for slowing down is there a mechanism
for the kinds of experimentation that
looks over long long periods of time
because there's no profit in that kind
of experimentation of that kind of
anthropology of over timeless as
currently built into these models and
that's what worries me well and Pat you
use the word profit which until then we
hadn't talked about it and which values
really are governing here is one of the
central questions and if its efficiency
and profit that is a set of values that
I can respect but that's not to me
dignity equality public welfare and
we're not having a public conversation
about that we are bypassing the
democratic process secondly I and I
totally agree also with this point about
time the the sense of everything that's
done so quickly we don't have time to
reflect that certainly interferes with
the kind of process values that Eliot
talked about and even helping people
build some sense of trust participation
the the first rule of the Federal Rules
of Civil Procedure which is a metal rule
about how to interpret all the rules
says all these rules shall be
interpreted to ensure the just speedy
and efficient administration of justice
well guess what those point in opposite
directions just speedy and and so we we
have the competing goals and we do not
have a hierarchy for them and we adjust
and we moderate but I worry about path
dependence in the most literal sense of
you know remember y2k and the code that
was built on the code that was built on
the code and we've been learning about
genomic databases that are built on old
concepts that were rejected but they're
still they're about race or what have
you I worry about path dependence so in
speed things are built on top of other
things that are built on top of other
things that are very hard to undo very
very hard to undo and that worries me a
lot because once it's done where's the
motive the profit the time the patience
to undo it and the world has changed and
the you know power relations have
changed once the world has
changed and I also worry but maybe
there's a little silver lining here
about public and private so the very
fact that the big big decisions are
being made many of them by private
companies is worrisome for the reason
I've already said it's not public it's
not subject to public accountability
it's not subject to the norms of the
public on the other hand there may be
more room for experimentation than if it
were the government
and particularly around issues of speech
you know the private sector can be
regulating its own speech in a way that
the innocent in the United States the
government cannot regulate its speech
but I would just add one more word which
is forgiveness so we are not a forgiving
people and you know there are groups and
maybe all of us have grounds for
resentment for bad things that have
happened bad things that are happening I
think that they we're living in an age
of resentment and so people aren't
always being generous when there are
mistakes and then we really have
conflict I think we're living in a time
when the Enlightenment is trouble the
the idea that reason is something that
to be it should be valued that science
news objectivity democracy these are all
in trouble well one of the ideas in the
Enlightenment was that we could actually
avoid war if we found ways to elevate
those other values I were you we're
gonna have war in the most brutal
terrible way because the conflicts are
going to be huge and we won't have
processes or trust in them to resolve
them so in my view the stakes are about
as big as they can get
so really yeah
[Laughter]
my concern is not is that this is a
challenge not just about what we are
doing it's that we actually already are
disrupting government with a trustee
ship system a colonial system and and
until we recognize that power is already
in place but that's what worries me it's
it's it's not just the is becoming it's
already hot comb yeah absolutely
so do we have any questions come on
there's a hand right yeah hi my name is
Alan Carlson and I just retired from
working 40 years in state trial court
system so I know an enormous amount
about what goes on in trial courts I
didn't litigate Iran that the courts my
concern is about data and a couple of
you have touched on this and there's a
lot of data out there but my concern is
a lot of the data is irrelevant but we
keep dumping it all into the pot and
cook enough to and there's nothing about
AI that I've seen that sorts out
causation versus correlation so my
concern if you can address that is how
do we get past just cuz it's correlated
then this goes totally to the ideas of
ranking people about being released
which is appalling to me from my time in
the system is it is any progress being
made and it's fascinating if shoppies
got an idea about theories about this
but it seems to me we got to be careful
of what we dump into the pot before we
cook it in terms of data I would say
that computer science is working on it
seriously in other words so I think we
need to be more careful whether there is
causation versus correlation I mean
where you live is irrelevant to whether
or not you're gonna show up and
recidivate but it's in the system and it
can be in there subtly you know a zip
code an address a lot of things like
that so that's my concern is it are we
going in are we getting very far very
fast on dealing with that you're being
hesitant I'm not an expert but I don't
think so
hi everyone Rachel Cummings I'm a I'm a
professor at I'm Georgia Tech and I'm
also visiting at Simon's
for the term which is great so I'd like
to kind of turn the conversation back
towards like education and I know you
three plus a fourth in the audience coat
I dislike a computer science and law
cores and a curious what are some what
are some what are some kind of like
broader principles learned in that
experience in terms of how to like a
better collaborate across fields and
like also where there's some clear
opportunities like future collaboration
there rose through that course well
thanks for that
I think one one lesson for sure that I
learned was that there's hunger for this
conversation a huge hunger among the
computer science students and and a
hunger from the law students and others
as well a second lesson that I learned
is that actually working together on
something is a way to get deeper and so
Cynthia and I are going to try and other
iteration so our shop is going to try
another iteration I'm sure that Pat will
be trying another iteration I think
we're all going to be trying to find
ways to actually have people with
different training work together on
something rather than you know parallel
play as you might describe I think we
heard about some other examples at the
conference that was held the last three
days amazing conference people trying to
have
philosophers and Ephesus
in computer science classes but again
not just coming in to do guest lecture
being part of the problem sets and I
think that this is all the good it's
very striking to me that people my age
we are playing catch-up and the students
are digital natives and even if they're
law students they are much more
proficient than I am in being able to
move across systems and to know what the
issues are and so my hope is that we're
going to have much more student
participatory lead classes where people
like me are going to be learning if
anything more than the students so just
to just to expand on what Martha said it
actually is it was a conversation we had
this morning that what we did this first
time was more like the computer science
would present their things and then the
lawyers would comment on what those
words meant in law and then vice versa
but so that felt a little bit disengaged
you know so it was an interesting
experiment but I'm not sure how deep we
managed to get and the idea that Martha
told me that she and Cynthia are gonna
try next time is that it will be
actually what less topics and just for
each topic to try to really examine it
from a legal point of view and a
computer science point of view and go
deep and not just the surface level and
I think this question of time so next
time we will really like take
blockchains and smart contracts and
compare them to contracts and we hope
it'll work we're actually in the class
we're gonna offer in the fall have one
day with the students from all the
backgrounds together but then separate
days so that the law students will be
meeting separately which science
students mean separately to get deeper
structure of academia to have these
conversations requires a willingness
to have not just and it's it's cheaper
to have students coming in and having
these conversations but but actually to
support faculty from different
disciplines to come into a classroom and
have that kind of deep conversation and
you know the co taught a class with a
geneticist at Columbia and we argued for
a whole semester about the meaning of
the word natural I mean it just began
there in being able to not just sort of
each of us go to our you know Dictionary
of biological subsets and-and-and the
legal dictionary but actually to over
the course of a semester excavate what
each of us meant and to do it in a way
that I think that group dynamic changes
when you're doing that you're sort of
fish bowling a kind of mutual exchange
across authority and disciplinary lines
that is very different from what I have
encountered in other settings trying to
engage with geneticists at conferences
where I come in as a lawyer and it's
like trust me I'm a scientist you don't
know what you're talking about and it
never goes anywhere I mean there's a
real I think disciplinary prejudice
around between hard sciences and Social
Sciences that makes these conversations
very difficult so being conscious of the
academic siloing that prevents some of
us from happening in richer ways that
sounds like computer scientists unsaid
better well there was up that was
observed for those people who work in
both today people consistently said that
computer scientists actually or this
conference seems much more congenial
alright we've run way over time so net
positive I will end there and please
join me in thanking our panelists
you